dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir if we study the
laws of fluid motion from physics and
write a computer program that contains
these laws we can create wondrous fluid
simulations like the ones you see here
the amount of detail we can simulate
with these programs is increasing every
year not only due to the fact that
hardware improves over time but also the
pace of progress in computer graphics
research is truly remarkable
so is there nothing else to do are we
done with fluid simulation research oh
no no no no for instance
fluid solid interaction still remains a
challenging phenomenon to simulate this
means that the sand is allowed to have
an effect on the fluid but at the same
time as the fluid sloshes around it also
moves the sand particles with him this
is what we refer to as to wake up lling
note that this previous work that you
see here was built on the material point
method a hybrid simulation technique
that uses both particles and grids
whereas this new paper introduces proper
fluid solid coupling to the simpler
grid-based simulators not only that but
this new work also shows us that there
are different kinds of to wake up link
if we look at this footage with the
honey and the dipper it looks great
however this still doesn't seem right to
me we are doing science here so
fortunately we don't need to guess what
seems and what doesn't seem right this
is my favorite part because this is when
we left reality be our judge and compare
to what exactly happens in the real
world so let's do that
whoa there's quite a bit of a difference
because in reality the honey is able to
support the deeper one-way coupling of
course cannot simulate this kind of back
and forth interaction and neither can
weak to wake up link pull this off
and now let's see
yes there we go the new strong two-way
coupling method
finally gets this right and not only
that but what I really love about this
is that it also gets small nuances right
I will try to speed up the footage a
little so you can see that the honey
doesn't only support the deeper but the
deeper still has some subtle movements
both in reality and in the simulation a
plus love it so what is the problem why
is this so difficult to simulate one of
the key problems here is being able to
have a simulation that has a fine
resolution in areas where a fluid and
the solid intersect each other if we
create a super detailed simulation it
will take from hours to days to compute
but on the other hand if we have a two
course one it will compute the required
deformations in so few of these grid
points that will get a really inaccurate
simulation and not only that but we will
even miss some of the interactions
completely this paper proposes a neat
new volume estimation technique that
focuses these computations to where the
action happens and only there which
means that we can get these really
incredible results even if we only run a
relatively coarse simulation I could
watch these gooey viscous simulations
all day long if you have a closer look
at the paper in the description you will
find some hard data that shows that this
technique executes quicker than other
methods that are able to provide
comparable results this episode has been
supported by weights and biases weights
and biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning
projects it can save you a ton of time
and money in these projects and is being
used by open AI Toyota Research Stanford
and Berkeley in this blog post you see
that with the help of weights and biases
it is possible to write an AI that plays
the witness one of my favorite puzzler
games if you are interested in the game
itself you can also check out my earlier
video on it I know it sounds curious I
indeed made a video about a game on this
channel you can find it in the video
description and also make
to visit them through Wendy b.com /
papers w AMD b.com / papers or just
click the link in the video description
and sign up for a free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time